البرد قارص جدا ليال وانا وددت ان يعني ان
نتجول معكم في هذا المخيم الذي هو يعني في
حديقه بين شارعين هذه طبعا اسر تركيا
وسوريا ويعني من الجميع من كل من تضرروا
وسقطت بناياتهم يسكنون هذه الخيام يشعرون
النيران منهم اطفال ومنهم نساء وانا ساجول
في الكاميرا طبعا
المشكله الحقيقيه ان البرد قارص جدا وهذه
العائلات
لم تبلغ حتى هذه اللحظه ما الخطوه التاليه
في حياتهم بعد هذه الخيام يعني هل ستكون
الحياه باكملها بالنسبه لهم
في خيام ام سيتغير الحال وستكون هنالك خطه
بديله لهم في اقادم الايام اعدادهم كبيره
اغلبهم من السوريين من العائلات السوريه
التي فقدت منازلها
باتت للاسف الشديد في الشارع طبعا
غذاء متوفر ماء متوفر ولكن البرد الشديد
هو اكبر تحدي لهم وخصوصا للاطفال كنت
تحدثت الى بعض العائلات طبعا تاتي منظمات
دوليه واطباء يعني
يقوموا بفحص الاطفال هنالك طبعا
الانفلونزا بين الاطفال من الجراء البرد
الشديد منتشره بينهم وهنالك طبعا سعال
شديد بين الاطفال وهنالك مرضى سكري من
النساء والرجال في هذا المخيم كنت شاهدتهم
اليوم طبعا الاضاءه غير متوفره بشكل كامل
هنالك مولدات ان كنت تسمعي صوتها هم
يعتمدون في التدفئه وهنا
نعم وهنا عائله انا ودت يعني سريعا ان كان
لدينا وقت فقط اتحدث اليهم يعني يشرحوا
لنا ظروف الحياه هذه السيده المسنه مثلا
مصابه بالسكري ليال وهذا المرض المزمن
بسبب عدم تلقي العلاج المناسب يعني احدث
لديها مشكله في الحركه في رجليها وصارت
حركتها اصعب ووضع اصعب السلام عليكم
يعطيكم الف عافيه بدي اسلم اولا على الحجه
واتطمن على صحتها انا كنت شفتك اليوم وكنت
تعبانه شوي كيف صرتي الحمد لله رب
العالمين الحمد لله احسن الحمد لله
ما حدا لسه اجاكي عشان ادويه ولا عشان شيء
صح لان ما حدا عندي طيب هلا انت شو
هذا الجرح من ايش من السكر ولا من الزلزال
اه ايش صار له اصبعك من الزلزال
سلامتك الف سلامه طيب انا بس بدي اسالك
انت هلا المشكله في البرد الشديد بالنسبه
لك مؤذي للسكر انت شو تحتاجي علاج ايش
الاشياء اللي ناقصه عليه
حدا حكى معكم حدا بلغكم ايش راح يصير
ولا منظمات ولا اي حدا ولا حدا اجى
عمار هل العوده الى سوريا وارده لديهم
ساساله ساساله لا هو يقول انه هنالك منظمه
اتت واخبرتهم عن شيء
انا عندي ابن بالمشفى
كم طفل فقدتم
الله يبارك فيك وابوهم وضعه صعب اليوم كان
عنده عمليه وامبارح كانوا عاملين له عمليه
والحمد لله رب العالمين يعني انت بجوز اهم
شيء تريده الان هو المسكن طبعا
هاي عشره ايام ما حدا نزل المي
بالعرب
في حمام الله يكون بالعون بس عندي سؤال
سريع واخير هل النيه للعوده الى سوريا
حاضره ممكن ترجعوا لسوريا ممكن اذا تامن
الامن والامان
طريق معبر باب الهوى وعلى الشمال السوري
ما النا حدا بالمحرر المنطقه المحرره ما
لنا حدا احنا
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله تفرج الله يكون
في العون ان شاء الله تامل لكم مساكن
قريبا